Lucia: 我听到这首歌里面如果有需要
Lucia: I heard in this song, if there's a need
Jake:哦这个
Jake: Oh, this
Lucia: 如果不是如果
Lucia: If not, if
Lucia: 有一些需要和谐的词汇的话
Lucia: there are some words that need to be censored
Lucia: 你们会码掉吗
Lucia: will you guys bleep them out?
Lucia: 比如说f word这些的
Lucia: Like the f-word or something?
Jake:可能不会吧这不管了
Jake: Probably not, we don't really care about that.
Lucia: 啊这样吗
Lucia: Oh, really?
Alice:采集一下牡丹
Alice: Let's pick some peonies.
Alice:漂亮好喜欢
Alice: So pretty, I love them.
Jake: 原来我有一个帽子
Jake: Turns out I had a hat.
Jake: 我也觉得我没有戴帽子
Jake: I thought I wasn't wearing one.
Jake: 结果是有帽子
Jake: But I actually had a hat.
Lucia: 其实你也可以在上面再待一个
Lucia: Actually, you can wear another one on top.
Tasha: 你摄像头不带吗
Tasha: Aren't you bringing your camera?
Jake:戴
Jake: I am.
Jake: 他总共能录的不久
Jake: It can't record for long though.
Lucia: 哦这个地方好像北大
Lucia: Oh, this place looks like Peking University.
Lucia: 救命哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Help, hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈确实
Jake: Hahaha, it really does.
Alice:未名湖呃
Alice: Weiming Lake, huh?
Lucia: 对啊那个塔也很像伯牙塔
Lucia: Yeah, and that tower looks like Boya Tower.
Alice:通州分湖
Alice: Tongzhou Branch Lake.
Lucia: 比伯牙塔那个塔尖高一点
Lucia: It's even taller than Boya Tower's peak.
Jake: 对通州分塔通州分塔
Jake: Yeah, Tongzhou Branch Tower, Tongzhou Branch Tower.
Alice:这是芬塔哈哈
Alice: This is Fenta, haha.
Jake: 通州分塔
Jake: Tongzhou Branch Tower.
Jake: 没什么人
Jake: Not many people around.
Jake: 所以很适合跳舞
Jake: So it's perfect for dancing.
Jake: 有道理吧
Jake: Makes sense, right?
Tasha: 你也跳一跳你就知道了
Tasha: You should try dancing, then you'll see.
Jake: 哈哈哈就知道有多
Jake: Hahaha, then I'll know how...
Lucia: 这种剪辑出来很像抖音上那种尬舞
Lucia: This kind of editing looks like those awkward dances on TikTok.
Lucia: 就是我说那种突然开始跳舞的那种
Lucia: You know, the ones where they suddenly start dancing.
Jake: 啊啊啊是
Jake: Ah, yes.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice:有小鱼好多
Alice: There are so many little fish.
Lucia: 也不是不行
Lucia: It's not impossible.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Alice:啊小鱼苗
Alice: Ah, little fish fry.
Alice:跑啥呀
Alice: Why are you running?
Tasha: 跑啥
Tasha: Why run?
Alice:好多啊
Alice: There are so many!
Tasha: 没事
Tasha: It's fine.
Alice:就是那种特别小的
Alice: They're really tiny ones.
Alice:很多然后那种
Alice: So many of them.
Jake: 在蹦跶是吧
Jake: They're bouncing around, right?
Lucia: 小锦鲤吗
Lucia: Little koi fish?
Alice:对对对然后还有那种有颜色的
Alice: Yes, yes, and there are colorful ones too.
Lucia: 哎我看到了
Lucia: Oh, I see them.
Alice:然后这些小小的全是特别小的鱼苗
Alice: And these tiny ones, all just little fish fry.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia: 哈哈为什么不是小乌龟
Lucia: Haha, why not little turtles?
Alice:好多好多
Alice: So many, so many.
Lucia: 王八和乌龟是一种吗
Lucia: Are turtles and softshell turtles the same?
Lucia: 王八是甲鱼还是什么
Lucia: Is a softshell turtle a kind of turtle?
Jake: 是吗我也不知道
Jake: Really? I don't know either.
Lucia: 我不知道
Lucia: I don't know.
Lucia: 我也不知道啊
Lucia: I don't know either.
Lucia: 好吧那我们就姑且认为是同一种吧
Lucia: Well, let's just assume they're the same.
Jake: 对对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Lucia: 这里面好多鱼啊
Lucia: There are so many fish here.
Jake: 是说钓鱼啦钓
Jake: Are you talking about fishing?
Jake: 鼓掌有什么用
Jake: What's the point of clapping?
Jake: 鼓掌有什么用啊
Jake: 啊真的吗
Jake: Oh, really?
Jake: 鱼鱼鱼它鱼它有耳朵是吗
Jake: Fish, fish, do fish have ears?
Shure:  这素材够用吧
Shure: Is this footage enough?
Shure:  全吞了
Shure: Swallowed it all.
Shure:  那叫一个
Shure: That was...
Katrina:  地道道哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Authentic, hahaha.
Jake: 呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure:  天嘀嗒地嘀嗒滴答滴滴答
Shure: Tick-tock, tick-tock, tick-tock, tick-tock.
Shure:  滴滴答滴滴答
Shure: Tick-tock, tick-tock.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Shure:  我饿了想吃了
Shure: I'm hungry, I want to eat.
Jake: 和鱼一起吃
Jake: Eat with the fish.
Katrina:  开吃才走两步
Katrina: Just started eating and only took two steps.
Alice:还不吃挑食吗
Alice: Are you still being picky?
Tasha: 太大了
Tasha: It's too big.
Tasha: 可恶污染海洋了哈哈
Tasha: Darn it, it's polluting the ocean, haha.
Alice:你看那有一个逆流而上的鱼
Alice: Look, there's a fish swimming upstream.
Alice:海风往这边吹
Alice: The sea breeze is blowing this way.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
Alice:他非得往那边游
Alice: It insists on swimming that way.
Alice:他还游不动
Alice: But it can't swim.
Tasha: 这离上岸得多远啊
Tasha: How far is it from the shore?
Alice:哈哈哈不如随波逐流吧
Alice: Haha, why not just go with the flow?
Tasha: 我的妈呀
Tasha: Oh my gosh.
Tasha: 我真不敢想
Tasha: I really can't imagine.
Lucia: AI应该知道人类并不一直是理性人
Lucia: AI should know that humans aren't always rational.
Alice:哈哈还近一点
Alice: Haha, a bit closer.
Katrina:  啊人类
Katrina: Ah, humans.
Jake: 是是是你也很特殊
Jake: Yes, yes, you are special too.
Katrina:  这就是AI永远无法取取代人类的原因
Katrina: This is why AI can never fully replace humans.
Jake: 对哎呀不好意思不好意思
Jake: Right, oh sorry, sorry.
Lucia: 虽然我知道
Lucia: Although I know,
Lucia: 经济学家也老假设人类是理性人
Lucia: Economists always assume humans are rational.
Tasha: 那一个呢
Tasha: What about that one?
Katrina:  因为人类总会做一些莫名其妙的行为
Katrina: Because humans always do some inexplicable things.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina:  这就是人类
Katrina: That's just how humans are.
Jake: 局部是有逻辑的好吧
Jake: In some parts, it makes sense, okay?
Alice:AI无法理解的
Alice: AI can't understand that.
Jake: 局部上是有
Jake: In some parts, it does.
Jake: 就是你扔出去
Jake: Like when you throw it out.
Alice:超多小小小小小鱼苗
Alice: So many tiny, tiny fish fry.
Jake: 然后鱼吃披萨
Jake: And the fish eat pizza.
Lucia: 嗯啊那么小的也有竟然
Lucia: Hmm, they even have such small ones?
Jake: 对这个是合理的
Jake: Yeah, that's reasonable.
Jake: 然后你看到鱼真披萨
Jake: And then you see fish eating pizza.
Alice:对就超级超级小的
Alice: Yeah, they're super, super small.
Jake: 这个多少是有一点点过去了
Jake: This is kind of going a bit too far.
Jake: 虽然不多
Jake: Though not much.
Jake: 这些鱼应该什么都吃
Jake: These fish should eat anything.
Jake: 公园里的鱼都是杂食类的鱼
Jake: The fish in the park are all omnivorous.
Jake: 鱼肉会吃吗
Jake: Will they eat fish meat?
Jake: 有应该会
Jake: They probably will.
Jake: 应该他们会互相吃
Jake: They should eat each other.
Shure:  废话我们刚刚看了那个
Shure: Duh, we just saw that.
Lucia: 大鱼吃小鱼是吧
Lucia: Big fish eat small fish, right?
Jake: 嗯对
Jake: Yeah, right.
Shure:  发现海里鱼都是在吃自己的同类
Shure: We found that fish in the sea eat their own kind.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  然后评论难道猪能在海里吗哈哈哈
Shure: And then the comments were like, can pigs be in the sea? Haha.
Katrina:  哈哈在海里的不都鱼吗哈哈哈
Katrina: Haha, aren't all the creatures in the sea fish? Haha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Alice:颐和园的大雁都还挑食呢
Alice: Even the geese at the Summer Palace are picky eaters.
Jake: 这都吃完了
Jake: They finished all of this.
Jake: 哈哈哈这都吃完了这个
Jake: Hahaha, they finished all of this stuff.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Shure:  啊拿多累啊
Shure: Ah, it's tiring to carry so much.
Tasha: 在湖边喂喂鱼
Tasha: Feed the fish by the lake.
Jake: 喂人喂鱼
Jake: Feed people, feed fish.
Tasha: 如果去海滩边就会去喂薯条喂人
Tasha: If you go to the beach, you can feed people with fries.
Jake: 对啊一会要有海鸥怎么办
Jake: Yeah, what if there are seagulls?
Jake: 还有东西喂吗
Jake: Do we still have stuff to feed them?
Tasha: 麦当劳整点薯条
Tasha: Get some fries from McDonald's.
Jake:还有点渣
Jake: There's still some leftovers.
Alice:海鸥找点薯条喂他
Alice: Seagulls need fries, feed them.
Lucia: 去码头整点薯条
Lucia: Get some fries at the dock.
Jake: 还有点鸡肉
Jake: There's also some chicken.
Jake: 可以给他留着
Jake: We can save it for them.
其他人：这个可以扔一下吗
Others: Can we throw this?
Jake:哦还 有一盒好
Jake: Oh, there's still one box left.
Lucia: 啊哈哈哈哈抛洒
Lucia: Haha, throw it away.
Jake: 哦哦有存货
Jake: Oh, we have stock.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 骨灰哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Ashes, hahahahahaha.
Katrina:  好爽啊
Katrina: So satisfying.
Lucia: 披萨也可以算是种面子的骨灰是吧
Lucia: Pizza can also be considered a type of ashes, right?
Jake: 嗯对
Jake: Yeah, right.
Jake: 对小码头
Jake: Yeah, the small dock.
Jake: 这叫什么湖啊
Jake: What's this lake called?
Jake: 有名字吗
Jake: Does it have a name?
Katrina:  未名湖
Katrina: Unnamed Lake.
Alice:未名湖
Alice: Weiming Lake
Lucia: 未名湖
Lucia: Weiming Lake
Jake: 好哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Haha, okay
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Katrina:  AI又疑惑了哈哈
Katrina: The AI is confused again, haha
Tasha: 难道是我扔的不够远吗
Tasha: Could it be that I didn't throw it far enough?
Katrina:  别抢了别打了
Katrina: Stop grabbing, stop fighting
Lucia: 用AI识图识别这一块儿为北大是吗
Lucia: Is the AI recognizing this as Peking University?
Shure:  看好了
Shure: Watch this
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Jake: 这边可以预测哪只鱼可以吃得到
Jake: This can predict which fish will get it
Tasha: 我知道如果抢的话就会吃的香
Tasha: I know if you grab it, it will taste better
Tasha: 哈哈你看我的在那后面就不是吃
Tasha: Haha, look at mine, it's at the back, not eating
Tasha: 必须要抢才行
Tasha: You have to grab it
Katrina:  落点位置
Katrina: The landing spot
Shure:  你想往哪我就能过了
Shure: Wherever you aim, I can get there
Shure:  看那边去了
Shure: Look, it went that way
Tasha: 哇太小了
Tasha: Wow, it's too small
Tasha: 他们不吃
Tasha: They're not eating
Tasha: 你看开始抢着开始吃了
Tasha: Look, they're starting to grab and eat
Katrina:  问一下AI那是活的
Katrina: Ask the AI if that's alive
Shure:  那是活的吗
Shure: Is that alive?
Katrina:  那塑料袋吧
Katrina: That's a plastic bag
Jake: 啊还有死的呀
Jake: Oh, there are dead ones too?
Shure:  那是塑料袋还是鱼啊
Shure: Is that a plastic bag or a fish?
Tasha: 哦终于被吃到了
Tasha: Oh, finally got eaten
Jake: 那那个
Jake: And that one
其他人： 那鱼
Others: That fish
Jake: 就那飘着的吗
Jake: The one floating?
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Yeah
其他人： 那是浮漂吗
Others: Is that a float?
Jake: 哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my gosh
Katrina:  哎我去
Katrina: Oh my gosh
Jake: 这风有点大
Jake: The wind is a bit strong
Jake: 试试
Jake: Let's try
Alice:哎什么掉了
Alice: Oh, something
Tasha: 东西掉了
Tasha: Something fell.
其他人：你的手链吗
Others: Your bracelet?
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Tasha: 他的手链断了
Tasha: His bracelet broke.
Alice:真的假的
Alice: Really?
Katrina:  完了被女朋友骂死
Katrina: Oh no, his girlfriend is going to kill him.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake: 掉哪去了
Jake: Where did it fall?
Tasha: 掉到湖里了
Tasha: It fell into the lake.
Alice:未名湖里
Alice: In Weiming Lake?
Lucia: 狐狸
Lucia: Fox?
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake: 掉未名湖了
Jake: It fell into Weiming Lake.
Jake: 他自己应该记得吧
Jake: He should remember it himself, right?
Tasha: 记录下来了
Tasha: It's recorded.
Katrina:  我的眼镜应该看到了
Katrina: My glasses should have seen it.
Jake: 你自己也记了
Jake: You also noted it down.
Shure:  没救了
Shure: It's hopeless.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina:  滑动摩擦力太小了
Katrina: The sliding friction was too low.
Alice:好像也不是很深
Alice: It doesn't seem that deep.
Alice:要不提供点珍贵素材
Alice: How about providing some precious footage?
Lucia: 人类早期下水捕鱼素材
Lucia: Early human fishing footage.
Jake: 可以
Jake: Sure.
Tasha: 嘿
Tasha: Hey.
Shure:  这怎么还就剩鱼头了呢
Shure: Why is there only a fish head left?
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Damn.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Jake: 呃应该是被吃了嗯
Jake: Uh, it probably got eaten, yeah.
Tasha: 应该是被大鱼吃小鱼的时候吃掉了
Tasha: It must have been eaten when a big fish ate a small fish.
Tasha: 那条鱼不喜欢吃鱼头
Tasha: That fish doesn't like eating fish heads.
Alice:他应该吃鱼身子吧
Alice: It probably eats the fish body, right?
Alice:他不吃鱼头
Alice: It doesn't eat fish heads.
Jake: 是鱼头没什么肉不好吃
Jake: Fish heads don't have much meat, not tasty.
Katrina:  准备好回去下跪吧搓衣板
Katrina: Get ready to go home and kneel on the washboard.
Jake: 或者是别的一些生物
Jake: Or it could be some other creatures.
Jake: NPU那边有水獭
Jake: There are otters at NPU.
Jake: 水獭吃鱼
Jake: Otters eat fish.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: Ah.
Lucia: 有什么奇怪景象吗
Lucia: Anything strange happening?
Jake: 吃一半就丢路边
Jake: Just eat half and throw the rest by the roadside.
Lucia: 让我的让我的眼睛也看一看哈哈
Lucia: Let my eyes have a look too, haha.
Tasha: 哎有一头牛奶鱼
Tasha: Hey, there's a milkfish.
Alice:你看那看见没
Alice: Look at that, did you see it?
Alice:鱼面已经泡发白了
Alice: The fish noodles have turned white.
Alice:那个鱼的眼睛睁的贼大
Alice: The fish's eyes are wide open.
Katrina:  你也蛮抽象啊你也蛮抽象
Katrina: You're quite abstract, you know.
Lucia: 好可怕
Lucia: That's so scary.
Alice:你要捞一下吗
Alice: Do you want to scoop it out?
Lucia: 好可怕
Lucia: That's so scary.
Shure: 上哪捞去啊
Shure: Where would you scoop it out?
Lucia: 没就是我没绕过来之前
Lucia: No, before I came around...
Lucia: 我以为那是一片塑料
Lucia: I thought it was a piece of plastic.
Jake: 你问问问问有没有那大网子是吧
Jake: Ask if there's a big net, right?
Shure: 不用捞了不用捞了
Shure: No need to scoop it out.
Jake: 在哪啊
Jake: Where is it?
Shure: 沉进去了
Shure: It sank.
Tasha: 在那
Tasha: It's over there.
Jake: 那一片是吧
Jake: That piece, right?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake: 嗯吼
Jake: Uh-huh.
Jake: 跟鱼头在一块差不多
Jake: It's near the fish head, right?
Tasha: 就在鱼头附近
Tasha: It's near the fish head.
Jake: 让鱼头看看让鱼头看看
Jake: Let the fish head have a look.
Jake: 走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Jake: 去下一个景点
Jake: To the next spot.
Jake: 这是什么景点
Jake: What's this spot?
Tasha: 无边位于景点
Tasha: The infinity spot.
Alice:说明他完成了他的使命
Alice: It means it completed its mission.
Alice:帮你躲过一灾
Alice: It helped you dodge a disaster.
Tasha: 要一个清水平台区吧
Tasha: Should we find a clear water platform area?
Tasha: 下一个区
Tasha: The next area.
Shure:  有一个能交代就行
Shure: As long as there's something to explain.
Tasha: 把这一个
Tasha: Take this one.
Tasha: 然后掉掉成项链
Tasha: Then turn it into a necklace.
Jake: 啊这什么东西
Jake: Uh, what's this?
Katrina:  真的吗那是散开了
Katrina: Really? It came apart.
Lucia: 还有一个珠子
Lucia: There's another bead.
Jake: 在地上
Jake: On the ground.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  应该是我这个东西他他压的
Shure: Maybe it's my thing that's pressing on it.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah
Tasha: 和我那天翻墙一样损失了一颗
Tasha: Just like the other day when I climbed over the wall, I lost one too.
Jake: 你怎么会哦
Jake: How did you... Oh.
Jake: 哎呀好疼
Jake: Oh, it hurts so much.
Katrina:  那这一个串一下戴
Katrina: Then you can wear this one.
Katrina:  戴成项链吗
Katrina: Wear it as a necklace?
Tasha: 嗯sorry
Tasha: Hmm, sorry.
Katrina:  我心永在
Katrina: My heart is always with you.
Tasha: 我就想看
Tasha: I just want to see.
Tasha: 你会不会把这个垃圾扔到垃圾桶里面
Tasha: If you would throw the trash into the trash can.
Tasha: 但是结果你果然没有
Tasha: But in the end, you didn't.
Tasha: 你知道吗
Tasha: You know?
Tasha: 这是一种数据记录
Tasha: This is a kind of data recording.
Tasha: 但我无意识提醒的情况下
Tasha: Without my conscious reminder,
Tasha: 你究竟会不会扔
Tasha: Would you actually throw it?
Jake: 好数据
Jake: Good data.
Tasha: 已经你把你这个人记录下来了
Tasha: You've already been recorded.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Tasha: 是一个平时不会动脑子的人
Tasha: As someone who doesn't usually think.
Jake: 塔呢
Jake: Where's the tower?
Jake:塔在哪啊看不见
Jake: Where's the tower? I can't see it.
Tasha: 说是在这
Tasha: They said it's here.
Tasha: 好像刚刚吧
Tasha: Just now, I think.
Jake: 啊哪哪啊
Jake: Ah, where, where?
Jake: 哦挺厉害
Jake: Oh, pretty impressive.